The one last thing we need to understand before we
move on to the formulas in
trigonometry is
the concept of a function. In
trigonometry we come across various functions
but very few understand what a function is. It's
simple. A function is like this
box with two pipes in it.  Gets an input some
operation takes place inside and it gives
an output based on the operation that is
inside all that matters is what is
inside let's understand an example let this
be a function box the operation it does
inside is it multiplies every input with
five and  If this
box gets any input it
will multiply by 5 and gives an output
of 10 Similarly if it gets any input it will
give 3 by 5 15 as the
output if fo is the input it will give as  20
as the output so this box is our function the
function is written as f of x =
5x make noise you
understand this well it means that if we
substitute
B5 Tat Ch E 10 In
Trigonometry Ten Functions Are Given Various
Names Ch We Will See In The Coming
[Music]
Videos